Longtime Google executive Marissa Mayer is trading one search company for another.
On Tuesday, Mayer begins a new job as CEO at Yahoo.
On Monday, she resigned from her VP post at Google.
She was the company's first female hire.
Right now is a great time to be a woman in tech, but there's not enough women in tech.
During her 13-year tenure, Mayer oversaw many of Google's most successful products.
She's credited with making the simplistic look of Google's home page...
...with Gmail, with maps now, with location, with doing things in a very clean,...
...elegant style, and that is something Yahoo certainly can use.
Yahoo, a one-time tech darling, now ranks a distant third in market share for search.
Mayer will be the sixth person to occupy the CEO office in the past five years.
And though she is experienced, charismatic, well-spoken and has the technical chops,...
...turning Yahoo around will require a Herculean effort.
She's 37, she was number 20 employee at Google, I think she's worth quite a bit of money.
What kind of better challenge could there be?
To me, it seems like a huge opportunity. This could be a total career-defining moment for her.
In a press release from Yahoo, Ms. Mayer said,...
..."There is a lot to do and I can't wait to get started."
The hiring news surprised many tech analysts...
...who assumed Interim CEO Ross Levinsohn would be appointed to take the helm permanently.
And Mayer's name never appeared on any shortlist.
In San Francisco, I'm Sumi Das, cnet.com for CBS News.